bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du journal du
vendredi nous sommes le 4 décembre et
aujourd'hui nous parlerons de
l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école le
torchon brûle entre la municipalité et
les usagers du site
le conseil municipal vient d'adopter une
motion réclamant l'instauration d'une
plage de silence le dimanche entre 12h
et 15h le 36 37 qui reprend du service
le téléthon 29e édition ou d'envoi déjà
donné dans certaines communes nous
verrons les enjeux cette année avec
daniel fazan coordinateur des opérations
pour les yvelines et puis comme chaque
vendredi nous reviendrons sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
journée internationale du handicap
augmentation du nombre de contamination
du vih et communauté musulmane face aux
discriminations après les attentats le
téléthon 2015 débute donc en ce 4
décembre et pour certains c'était dès ce
matin à l'exemple de cette salle de
sport sur les clayes-sous-bois qui coule
qui a décidé pour chaque kilomètre
parcouru par ses adhérents sur ces
machines de reverser un euro à la fm en
2013 l'ensemble des salles affichant
l'ensemble des sages des salles
participant de cette de cet ancien en
france avaient totalisé huit mille six
cents kilomètres au compteur et autant
d'euros pour lutter contre la maladie
écouter la responsable de la salle des
clés c'est une opération ou pendant les
deux jours le 4 et le 5 donc un papier
est réservé exclusivement à cette
opération
chaque adhérent peut courir ou marcher
sur ce papier le nombre de kilomètres va
être relevé et à la fin les deux jours
ont fait les totaux et le nombre de
kilomètres égale le nom
re d'euros reversés à l'association du
téléthon on espère 150 km cette année
voilà plus on court plus en fait ils
omettent et plus aura deux remercié donc
aux adhérents de jouer en fait
propos recueillis par fanny bourdillon
et le téléthon nous en parlons plus en
détail dans quelques minutes avec le
coordinateur du département pour cet
événement daniel basons bons joueurs qui
nous cloue sur ce plateau est la ville
de saint cyr l'école vatel obtenir
l'instauration d'une plage de silence le
dimanche de 12 à 15 heures au près de
l'aérodrome les usagers s'inquiète et
dénonce une pression uniquement
justifiée afin de finaliser un projet
immobilier à proximité
william l pour les précisions d'ici
quelques mois les avions de l'aérodrome
de saint cyr l'école pourrait être cloué
au sol tous les dimanches entre 12h et
15h le 4 novembre dernier le maire sa
majorité et l'opposition ont voté une
motion favorable à une interdiction de
vol
c'est aux riverains de se porter toutes
les nuisances
il ya aussi ceux qui ont le droit de
pouvoir au moment où ils sont en repos
où ils sont chez eux pouvoir profiter
tranquillement pendant quelques heures
de leur jardin et de leurs balcons de
façon un pas avoir toutes les deux ou
trois minutes
le vrombissement d'un avion une motion
contestée par le groupement des usagers
de l'aérodrome pour le président elle
représenterait un premier pas vers une
fermeture et apparaît comme nouvelles
entraves qui s'ajoutent aux contraintes
météorologiques auxquels ils sont déjà
soumis les gens volent plus souvent le
week end c'est bien connu est également
ce qui concerne donc l'activité de
formation puisque ça représente 50% de
l'activité de l'aérodrome
cette activité avec des lycéens et des
étudiants s'effectue aussi beaucoup
durant le week end alors fermé
l'aérodrome à certains moments du week
end
ces handicapés l'activité d'autant plus
que en ce moment le soleil se couche à
17h et l'aérodrome est fermée après il
ya quelque part une sorte de
volonté de faire plier les pilotes mais
si nous plions nous craignons la
disparition pure et simple de
l'aérodrome
les hélicoptères seraient la première
nuisances sonores devant les avions dont
90% sont déjà équipés de silencieux
d'échappement réduisant considérablement
cette gêne une étude pour mesurer
séduisant sera réalisée courant 2016
le maire quant à lui va interpeller le
préfet la motion n'interdisant pas pour
l'instant aux avions de voler l'aviation
est une activité d'intérêt général
la décision reviendra au ministère des
transports nous revenons à l'actualité
principale de ce vendredi qui va
d'ailleurs être la qualité de tout ce
week-end on marche des élections
régionales bien évidemment c'est le
téléthon 29e édition daniel base ont
donc été avec nous en plateau aux
coordinateurs des événements sur les
yvelines l'objectif bien sûr c'est de
récolter des fonds des dons en faveur de
la recherche sur les maladies rares
les animations sont elles nombreuses
cette année elles sont très nombreuses
lui dire comme chaque année on ne baisse
pas on paie un des manifestations
l'année dernière c'est en un peu cette
année 106 avec une exception on peut
dire des années précédentes
depuis 2006 que je suis coordinateur
c'est la première année où en bois st
j'ai fait 26 nouvelles manifestations au
moins deux villes aux manifestations qui
sont organisées enfin les anciennes se
retire du jeu un petit peu et de nouvel
appareil je donnais 20 nouvelles manifs
à louis en un
ben regroupe un jeu sur vélizy de
l'ensemble des manifestations des
petites manifestations qui se regroupent
auprès de la mairie
donc censé on peut dire que c'est un
plus pour nous parce que la réunion sont
que les municipalités et vincent prenant
du téléthon on a quelques défections
mais bon ça c'est tous les ans on a
toujours des pères qu'est ce qui
explique le l'arrêt de certaines
manifestations se sont tenues un
bénévole qui sont occupés qui voit là où
il ya un manque de bénévoles
il ya une faiblesse et puis je crois
aussi que les bains malheureusement les
élections nous un petit peu bloqué les
salles qui sont prises pose elle est
pour les élections
donc nous organisateurs ne sont pas
venus à nous pour quand les incite à
faire quelque chose après donc on a des
pertes qui est un petit peu comme ça
dans les différentes petites communes
parce que vous dise après ça peut être
des manifestations peu plus tard dans la
semaine même le onetwo cela fait 36 37
qui ouvre ce week-end sera encore ouvert
quelques jours après des semaines après
je n'autorise ou même parce que tout le
monde le sait on a besoin d'argent je
n'autorise même encore au mois de
février
j'ai encore une grosse manifestation qui
va se passer après le 15 un hippodrome
l'ipo dont 1
donc le bipe ic2 versari sur les
différents rendez-vous qui sont créés
vous nous disiez une vingtaine ce qui
est assez historique pour le département
vingtaine de nouvelles manifestations
qui sont eux qui est à l'origine de ces
différentes manifestations cd des
bénévoles qui soudainement décide de
s'impliquer
quel est le profil de ceux qui auraient
beaucoup d'entreprises maintenant qui
viennent
délicieux toussaint qui essaie
d'organiser quelque chose et puis ben on
a une grosse grosse manifestation bien
sûr mon vélodrome de saint quentin donc
qui va tourner et on va avoir un fil
rouge qui va tourner de ce soir jusqu'à
demain soir
dès ce vendredi soir les animations dans
les yvelines pour le téléthon rapporte
combien parce que vous disais tout à
l'heure on a besoin d'argent pour faire
fonctionner cette recherche sur les
maladies rares les yvelines mai dernier
avant de voter le chief on était passé 1
421 donc j'espère arriver un ce chiffre
voire même l'objectif c'est de le
dépasser mais malheureusement on peut
pas trop s'avancer un banc avec les
dents le produit moyen 400000 euros
quatre cent mille euros c'est l'objectif
minimum oui oui mais si on peut les 450
jeunes seraient plutôt que fier au
niveau national il ya eu 1 re de départ
un petit peu à la hausse sur les sur les
dons après quelques années de baisse
vous êtes plutôt optimiste justement eux
il ya le contexte il ya eu on va aussi
parler peut-être des manifestations sur
l'organisation dans un instant avec la
question des attentats peut-être que ça
à jouer aussi sur l'organisation les
difficultés vous avez pu rencontrer
ça a peut-être joué aussi sur la
participation des gens pour venir tout
simplement globalement le là c'est
reparti à la hausse on cgper qui enfin
une participation mot niveau des non
moins je suis pas trop inquiet là dessus
parce que même si les gens ne viennent
pas il donne malgré douanes qui avaient
malgré tout les fronts si ce sont des
grands donateurs surtout au niveau du
thé les temps et je les remercie
énormément sur la question des attentats
justement ça peut jouer sur la
fréquentation ou en tout cas sur votre
organisation ça a été compliqué à gérer
c'est un peu joué oui c'est très
compliqué à gérer parce que on
à la dernière minute on ne savait pas
s'il y avait des manifestations qui nous
seraient interdites ou quoi et puis
comme les oméga d'urgence puisque le
préfet doit décider au cas par cas dans
la sécurité est assurée au vélodrome et
ben on ne sait pas si demain soir pour
severino aussi maintenant le vélodrome
serait incomplet on ne sait pas sur les
événements notables on va revenir à
l'aspect festif aussi parce que c'est
une fête derrière tout ça sur les
événements notables qui sont organisées
dans le département vous avez vocal
vélodrome accueille cette année y'a
guyancourt bien sûr qui fait comme
chaque année magny les hameaux
montigny on a eu les manifestations se
développe
trump qui chaque année c'était très
difficile
là il ya quelque chose qui est organisé
au niveau de la ville de trappes et j'en
remercie les organisateurs
non non moi je je suis assez confiant
dans les dons qui vont être fait
maintenant la participation 500 points
ça pourrait peut-être jouer ça fait des
années que vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous vous êtes coordinateur
c'est ce téléthon dans le département
quelle est votre plus beau souvenir du
téléthon eh ben je vais dire chaque
année c'est certainement eu un beau
souvenir parce que c'est une fête et
parce qu'elle rencontre totalement
ficelé au market avec les organisateurs
ou là on a
accueil qui aurait montré très
chaleureux magny les hameaux là où en
accueillir très un bras ouverts par
notre ami daniel thurman qui sera qui
sera l'invitée d'ailleurs du journal
lundi pour faire un petit débriefing de
montigny c'est pareil dans icmp va là on
n'a que 18 ans l'équipe rhénane en a qui
fait qu'un événement et réussir c'est la
passion que les bénévoles vont mais
c'est leur passion parce que bon nous c
était du travail mais réellement j'en
remercie tous les organisateurs qui ont
pu maintenir notre manifestation comme
villepreux le vilain vous il ya eu
quelques petits soucis d'apporter un
petit peu de deux salles tout ça mais
bon la sécurité est prise
donc on espère et ben ça sera réellement
un week-end de fait alors on le rappelle
pour vos dons c'est le 36 37
comme chaque année vous pouvez donner
pour pour le téléthon pour aider la
recherche sur les maladies rares et puis
il y aussi les dons que vous pouvez
faire lors des différentes animations
qui sont organisées on vient d'en parler
à l'instant comment ça se passe pour la
partie de l'argent qui est collecté sur
les différentes animations aussi
peut-être pour expliquer aux gens qui
vont qui vont venir et qui vont donner
de l'argent qu'elle est le quelle est la
trame ensuite comment ça se gagne à
leurs yeux une partie qui va à la
recherche c'est sûr il ya une partie
aussi qui va à l'aide aux familles
et puis
le siège de la fm les chercheurs tout ça
donc c'est des salariés donc sur la
collecte même vous comment vous
organisez c'est surtout le surtout sur
les recettes mais ni salariés sont payés
sur une partie on me dira plutôt des
recettes non vous récupérer l'argent
vous centralisez vous fait un chèque
global
quelque 90 chiens de guerre vers son
site g1 qu'organisateur nous amène des
chiens que voilà on comptabilise tous et
ses envoyés après où siègent
on est là pour aider la recherche sur
les maladies rares et on rappelle que
les dons sont déductibles des impôts
aussi pour ceux qui hésiteraient encore
merci daniel basant d'être passé en
plateau en plein lancement de ce
téléthon 2015 il va se poursuivre tout
au long du week end
vous pouvez participer à l'aide des
nombreux rendez-vous l'a vu le 36 37
et puis bien évidemment nous en
reparlerons à lundi dans le journal de
la rédaction nous ferons un petit
débriefing notamment avec le responsable
de l'organisation sur magny les hameaux
manic et toujours en général le volume
est très active et qui récolte beaucoup
de fonds et qui propose une telle
flexibilité
merci encore daniel fazan nous passons
maintenant à la suite de cette édition
du week-end de votre journal
nous poursuivons comme chaque vendredi
avec l'essentiel de la semaine les
principaux sujets traités dans le
journal du lundi au jeudi le zapping de
l'info locale tout de suite ils étaient
plus de 400 à rejoindre le convoi qui
s'est installé devant le château de
versailles venue de dijon agen ou bur
de nombreux militants contre l'aéroport
de notre dame des landes des analystes
de toute la france ou des sympathisants
sont venus pour apporter leur soutien on
est venu à accompagner les l'équipe qui
est venu en vélo là de notre dame des
landes et noël approche à la ville
d'elancourt a décidé de réinstaurer les
illuminations de noël pour autant après
les avoir supprimées pendant deux hivers
de structures lumineuses géantes ont été
inaugurées comme vous pouvez le voir et
hier à la mairie de la commune et dans
le centre commercial 17 mars
l'idée première c'était pas de vivre
trente ans pour les restos du coeur
c'était de dépanner sur plutôt le court
terme des gens qui étaient dans la
pauvreté le besoin et qu'est ce qu'on
voit c'est que alors qu'au début on a dû
servir 50 mille repas maintenant on en a
servi au niveau national sens rampillon
donc c'est et d'une année sur l'autre on
continue si on voit pas ni de récession
cette année pas d'augmentation pas de
récession toujours de les mêmes qui
viennent nous voir
journée internationale de lutte contre
le sida le nombre de contaminations et
en os
les initiatives se multiplient pour
sensibiliser la population
nous irons dans un lycée de trappes qui
a décidé d'utiliser l'art pour
interpeller les élèves sur ce sujet chez
noyon cours on va organiser des journées
portes ouvertes pour que nos concitoyens
les voisins viennent à la mosquée doive
partagent un thé avec nous et posent
leurs questions
nous sommes nous serons ouverts
l'événement sera organisé d'ici la fin
de l'année une date sera précisée
l'objectif c'est d'ouvrir la porte et
d'accueillir tous les clips concitoyens
quelles que soient leurs origines et
leur religion pour débattre sur les
sujets poser des questions et lever les
amalgames puisque je moi un moment qu'on
parle en mal de dos nous avons trois
fois plus de documents alors qu'ils sont
ceux qui souhaitent justement intégrer
l'armée s'était justement les attentats
de paris du 13 novembre dernier et est
ce que vous avez justement besoin de ces
candidatures nous avons besoin de ces
candidatures
puisque comme comme vous le savez le
président de la république a décidé
d'augmenter de 11000 m
la forte être ici des michettes et fait
john key qui viennent dans tout ça un
peu comme en fonction tous nos vins
français qui ont entre 17 ans et demi
fronton c'est avec ce casque que jean
baptiste gressins servi aux côtés des
anglais dans la royal air force en 1942
à 95 ans il se rappelle des ordres comme
si c'était hier
lascorz by relève philippe match pour
moi cela français c'est vivant et je
suis toujours prêt à donner et c'est
arrivé un plaisir pour moi de donner
william bertrand 13 ans et déjà un as du
volant sans son permis en poche
ce jeune sportif néo chine et fait
aujourd'hui partie des trois meilleurs
jeunes pilotes de kart de l'hexagone
dans la quête
le cas d un sport qu'il a démarré en
2011 aux racines carte de corneille
c'est mon père un jour on allait faire
un tour en location et j'ai beaucoup
aimé ça et donc depuis vanhée aller plus
loin et on avait la compétition trois
jours à 6,39 saignant et un dessert
habana une tatin s'il vous plaît c'est
un concours qui se divise en trois
parties il ya d'abord une partie sur
l'a20 qualifications régionales
c'est une finale régionale qui mois pour
moi était dans l'île de france
ensuite il y avait la demi finale
nationale et le maintenant j'en suis à
la finale la grande finale se jouera ce
lundi 7 décembre où les dix meilleurs
apprentis de france s'affronteront dans
une épreuve de 4h30
chaque fin de semaine dans ce journal
les enfants réagissent aussi à
l'actualité locale et à l'actualité
nationale une séquence toujours préparé
par william elle avec les jeunes du
collège les soldes guyancourt c'est une
sorte d un événement en fait qui
qui récoltent de l'argent par recherche
pour pour les handicapés pour les
maladies graves
sauf que c'est bien de récolter de
l'argent pour aider les personnes parce
que voilà comment il faut quand même
faire de recherche ne faut pas laisser
les personnes comme ça que leur maladie
et en plus on sait pas si la maladie est
mortelle si ça peut s'acquérir donc on
fait des émissions on peut faire des
matches de foot et les mages
d'athlétisme des spectacles pour oreca
et donc pour en faire part à la télé
tout je vais me battre breux je vais
courir eux me bats je vais aux pauvres
il y aura des gros des lancers des poids
des langueurs des des sceaux je trouve
que c'est bien enfin c'est une bonne
aide
donc il faut continuer à faire ça même
sans guérir la maladie a soulagé tout ça
pratique - tout le monde pense sûrement
que il peut aller n'importe où ils
veulent mais en fait c'est pas trop le
cas comme par exemple s'il veut faire
des courses je sais pas moi leclerc et
ébats peut-être qu'elle des escalators
et ils doivent monter comment ils font
ils sont obligés de prendre l'ascenseur
vous voir c'est pas non plus être libre
mon club en fauteuil roulant qu'on va
descendre du métro et des escaliers on
est obligé de porter et c'est bien quand
même essayer de récolter de l'argent
pour s'est trouvé comment dire des
méthodes pour que ça ait mieux voilà
pour améliorer la vie des gens qu
handicapées et le programme complet du
téléthon qui débute donc aujourd'hui ce
vendredi sera retrouvée dans le 7-8 week
end présenté préparé par mélanie poké
cette semaine le point complet tous les
événements disséquer avec ses aises
invités l'actualité locale revient est
dès lundi en direct à 18h sur notre
antenne avec florane parfait première
rediffusion 19 heures et aussitôt en
replay sur notre site internet
un peu moins de vingt jours de noël nous
verrons les principales tendances en
termes de cadeaux comment faire plaisir
à coup sûr aux plus jeunes
et puis bien sûr comment bien choisir
son
sapin ils s'en vont un peu plus de 5
millions tout de même chaque année à
travers toute la france
l'actualité de la semaine prochaine ce
sera également la dernière ligne droite
de la coop 21 après les discours des
chefs d'états à l'heure est aux
décisions
en tout cas elles sont attendues à
l'association greenpeace basée dans les
yvelines proposera une réunion le 11
décembre pour dresser un premier bilan
se sera avérée dans un instant donc le
7-8 week-end il sera question du
téléthon et des autres événements
organisés dans le cadre de vos loisirs
et puis dès à présent si vous aimez l le
cirque je vous invite à noter les unique
représentation en ile de france 2 et
cliniques king ethnique digne pis
tricoter la paix c'est plus simple en
français c'est du cirque et du ski arts
du cirque scandinave contemporain pour
toute la famille à partir de 10 ans
équilibrisme jonglage trapèze acrobaties
diverses pour un spectacle tout en
métaphore sur une thématique
malheureusement plus que jamais
d'actualité à noter que les
représentations de vendredi de samedi
sont à 20h30 dimanche c'est à 16h et
c'est au théâtre de saint quentin en été
le spectacle s'appelle knitting pis donc
tricoter la paix c'est vraiment tout
basé en fait autour de la laine et
l'utilisation de la laine pour raconter
un peu voilà comment on peut améliorer
ce monde et tendre un peu sur quelque
chose de positif et sur la paix c'est
très poétique c'est très visuel
c'est beaucoup d'acrobaties évidemment
ce spectacle qui prend tout un sens
aussi un peu supplémentaires dans les
eaux
le contexte d'aujourd'hui enfin pour moi
je sais que c'est encore plus important
de jouer ce spectacle encore plus parce
qu'ils parlent de paix est forcément
interview réalisée par sephora namani
c'est ainsi que se referme cette édition
du vendredi n'oubliez pas lundi aux
alentours de 18h15 édition spéciale du
7-8 politique je vous retrouverai pour
un point complet sur les résultats du
premier tour des régionales à lundi donc
et n'oubliez pas d'aller voter dimanche